[Music]
[Music]
all right
shut up
[Music]
a little more actually all this
aggravation ain't
less far satisfactional little less
fight a little more small close your
mouth and open up your heart baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
walk
[Music]
it's time to kick ass into bubble gum
i'm all out of gold
somebody's gonna freaking pay for
screwing up my vacation
shake it baby
your face your ass what's the difference
you guys done
[Music]
okay i think we know where to go now
there we go what up homies what up guys
good in the hood
yeah we're doing our best here um mike
won't take a picture of the deplorable
choir i don't know why
no um the new robinson's here we're
going to trump's here that's a big head
are you having fun are you not
[Music]
it is worn in there
let's see what's going on over here
oh let's check out some good music
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh check this guy check this out
[ __ ] leaving in america
my name is mindy robinson i don't know
if you know me from twitter
but
than being in a um full of this much
love and painting
you guys are needed
we'll put on the cheesy games
[Music]
[Music]
amazing yeah here tonight but the two
people
i want to mention right off the bat
[Applause]
don't have time to play with myself
right now look at that look at those
shoes look at those boat shoes
check that out guys get a lot of boomers
but there is there's
[Music]
nobody
[Music]
[Music]
water doesn't curve
[Music]
you're flat
damn it no way i'm eating this [ __ ]
i'm gonna get medieval on your asses
that's juanita broderick that's what
nina broderick the one that was famously
raped by bill clinton
i'm a libertarian at heart okay 1776.
you do what you want don't listen no
she's not the boss of you
have any of you guys haven't been on the
platter with crowder show
how he like
[Music]
let god
i like your shirt man awesome you live
streaming yeah i'm live streaming
youtube youtube what's up youtube what's
the name of your channel yeah uh
revenge of the sis assist yep nice
nice nice yeah thank you you got a
channel
since i've been out here and they all
look like that dude
are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah
he was [ __ ]
[Music]
ashley st claire who looks nothing like
her pictures
that that guy keeps touching the
deplorable choir girl and it's becoming
very very awkward
watch watch how he keeps touching her
watch how awkward this is
what there's oh one of you
see you in hell you want to say hello
[Music]
he's gotta be [ __ ]
[Music]
intricacies of strip clubs looks like
it's time for me to go
postal
mr valley saw he does an awesome job
so hit him up if you see him anywhere
around
can i get a vodka tonic
[Music]
where the [ __ ] did mersch go
and i'm gonna be there
[Music]
[Applause]
that makes fun of me affording a vodka
time
[Music]
are you going to go mingle for a bit i
did
i was out there
all right guys i'm gonna hop off
later bye bye
american
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up guys hola what's up kids
we're at uh stoney's bar and grill for
the uh
event we got help we got we got help
[Music]
huh
yeah mike drank a lot last night mike
drank a a lot last night
uh yeah we'll walk around here in a
second
hey what's up you want to say hi
[Music]
show revenge of this film and we're
filming everything yeah
yeah cool all right
that guy's face taste is not impressed
can you take one thing seriously in your
life
sir um um let me want me to take the
first little walk around
yeah do a little walk around all right
i'm gonna do a little walk around
thank you a.t by the way for filming
yeah these are what i do
and very helpful really hopefully we
could uh have you shoot somebody
aiming for a warship you know amy man oh
my god
[Music]
all right i gotta ask
all right
hello how are we all doing tonight
so my whole thing is i'm trying to kind
of break away
the democrats stronghold on the
gay community because
[Applause]
how can i be a gay trump supporter the
short answer is
how can i
[Applause]
[Music]
i will help you
please welcome comedian evan saint
[Applause]
the democratic party they're stupid
[Music]
[Music]
i am a four-time new york times
best-selling author two books
endorsed by a sitting president many of
you will recognize me from television
[Applause]
as you can tell the audience doesn't
really care i'll be ready to go
and voted for impeachment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i wonder when the show is starting i
thought it started okay what is favorite
okay
i don't think rape is funny
the nose never lies
[Music]
williams
but i don't want to catch the blue
[Applause]
[Music]
you know you chat room people are not
being nice i just want to say that
i'm reading your comments and you're not
nice people that i made
this is bar trivia what do you want
we're getting a drink folks what should
i drink appletini
midori
here you go guys something for the
fellas
something is happening here but why are
you advising us or something yeah
so um
[Music]
the camera is filming that girl i'm
filming everything
ladies and gentlemen
don't talk to me please leave me alone
the tumor
culturally militarily economically or
excuse me
[Music]
in almost 5 000 years
[Applause]
reduction
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
but you know what we don't care we're so
surprised
we're all under 10.
[Applause]
[Music]
real women
[Music]
[Music]
blood
[Music]
i hope you guys appreciate the things
that we do for you i really do hope you
guys appreciate
[Music]
they don't they don't um where'd mers go
[ __ ] i was looking for him all right
well merci's in outside guys
so now i have to walk inside like an
[ __ ]
i thought murray was outside
[Music]
[Music]
uh it's a little chilly out here in
vegas the fremont street's pretty packed
it's bumping
a lot of street drummers fremont street
is kind of like
time square if prostitutes are even more
legal
so it's cool i like it i think it's
pretty cool
right exactly we'll go for a walk here
in a little bit we're just right now
enjoying some drinks
i know my mustache looks fine but i want
to make sure it's impeccable
don't don't [ __ ] talk down to me guys
i don't give a [ __ ] who you are [ __ ]
talk down to me
all right you want my buddy the skeleton
to take you out
[Applause]
i don't think you do dude i don't think
you do bro stay away from uncle david
stay away from uncle dave comment down
below if that's true
comment down below if that's true
[Music]
what say oh you should flat smack some
people too
we have to can't forget the flat smack
earth is flat the earth is flat you've
been lied to
200 earth is flat everybody
[Music]
here you guys can see what we're seeing
hopefully the boomers are mad that i'm
filming hot chicks
something for the fellas there you go
guys
should we flat smack the ladies
we're about to go flat
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
if i want to buy you a drink at some
point
i just thought um
[Applause]
[Music]
they didn't do it they didn't go they
didn't go for it guys
[Music]
is for wizards it's a dinner city
degenerates and wizards guys
all right let's go we're walking we're
walking
dragons
a dragon dragons aren't real
these are dinosaurs oh it's chilly
look how chilly it is i don't know why
everybody's
okay first off mike it's current year
and you're allowed to be
we're just walking
[Music]
i live life a quarter mile at a time but
i'm a good fast and furious fan
family and family crap
all right let's turn it around let's
check out the bar let's take out the
[Music]
bike
[Music]
are we leaving all right let's see we're
leaving
good job by the way it's a lot of fun
not interrupting it's not your show
[Music]
you guys should change your names yeah
[Music]
oh that's a new form of ecstasy it's
called light
pretty good
[Music]
we're back we're back this part's darker
in a good way not like in a bad way in a
good way not a bad way
[Music]
[Music]
dance
[Music]
yes
and i've been doing this since i was one
years old
a little less i'm going to use the
bathroom you're going back in my pocket
all right
me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's see let me save me a seat
then it's taking a seat guys they're
featuring this [ __ ] all of them
didn't even save me a seat
all right i'm probably going to hop off
rock and roll generic again
game over you'll never defeat
[Music]
we're heading out all aircraft reports
one of the best things i've probably
ever seen
in my entire life
[Music]
i like black people i swear
none of this [ __ ] is fun we need to get
back to work